Và hồi 12 giờ bố mi tám phút hôm nay 2018,
tả nha như khu trăm ha mới làm.
Tại của lộ một thủ đều phản thôn thập nhất,
Sá Nhili, Tình Lặng Sơn,
sẽ ra vụ tên ánh rã thông đặc biệt nghiêm trọng khiến những người thương vòng.
Thưa điểm trên, sẽ đầu kéo chim mi tám a khu khu khu khu khu khu khu khu khu bẩy bẩy,
gió tại CPVD, sinh 1 miền chính trăm tám mi một,
chú tại tình bắt ninh, đều khiến hướng hà nội Lặng Sơn,
đã vào trạng với Sécor Mì chính á bố Nghó Tám ba, mở bà.
Hành người còn lại bị thương đã được đưa đi cấp thủ, trong đó còn lại xe.
Muy nhiên, sợ bộ sắp định,
Tại Sécor đi không đúng là đường gây tên ánh rau thông.
Lãnh đạo hi bán nhân dân tình, bán ánh tỏng ra thông tình,
không ăn tình là sơn đã tổ chức pham hoa,
đúng viên các gia đình là nhân với sốt tiền nám triệu đồng mong người tử pham,
hai triệu đồng mong người bị thương.